en 2017 le maire se déplace est ici en
chaîne
moi je fais natale avait le mental c'est
du jamais vu deux montagnes étaient
durement touché plus de 250 résidences
inondées des dommages de plus de 15
millions de dollars
pas seulement le long de la rive mais
loin à l'intérieur dans les zones les
plus basses aujourd'hui le lac déborde
encore comme il ya deux ans mais le
maire denis martin a les pieds au sec
c'était comme ce qu'on appelle
l'autoroute de lol en adaptant à que la
maaf a par endroit les chaloupes qui
passait là on est au sec parce que dès
que le niveau d' alerte du lac a été
atteint à la mi avril
la ville a complété un réseau de digues
avec 3000 blocs de béton et de la glaise
de mirabel en 72 heures seulement
un travail de titan
doucement mon travail à colmater les
brèches assurer que nos pompes
fonctionnent que le touran et les
autoradios
les habitants de deux-montagnes n'en
reviennent pas et ils félicitent leur
maire et son équipe à ce que le miracle
en fait c'est une bonne préparation en
une fois remise de ses émotions la
municipalité s'est attaqué immédiatement
à la tâche pour éviter une nouvelle
catastrophe
on avait déjà acheté des blocs ddt dans
les parcs on avait tout préparé le plan
n'est générée pas comment la paire
comment la fabriquer au cas où on aura
les urgences
la ligne de chemin de fer de deux
montagnes traverse les eaux à la
jonction de la rivière des mille îles et
du lac des deux montagnes
la ville est au bord du lac
quand l'eau monte ça va vite et elles
restent longtemps la ville de sainte
marthe et à l'ouest à cet endroit et
c'est là où je souhaite l'arrivée à
démêler la suite en alava qui est aux
côtés si laval sur le lac laval-ouest
soit on sera vraiment vers le secret de
la réussite se trouve dans cette carte
quand vous voyez la trace et un rocher
la langue était non dès 2010 atteint le
niveau de nos actuels freinent les zones
les plus inondées il ya deux ans sont en
couleur plus foncée
ceci est un projet pilote de la ville et
de la communauté métropolitaine de
montréal une vaste région qui comporte
82 municipalités 4 millions d'habitants
sur plus de 4000 kilomètres carrés avec
un fleuve et un vaste réseau de rivières
et de lacs
une équipe de seize personnes hydrologue
géomaticien ingénieurs sous la direction
de massimo iezzoni c'est un cocktail de
mesures qui est proposée encombre à la
wii à la digue
we watched were oui à d'autres mesures
qui vont nous permettre de capter l'eau
de la stocker d'évacuer
c'est ce qui fait que c'est un projet
réside y un cocktail de mesures
requalification et nous on pense qu'avec
ça on peut gérer les zones inondables
avec les citoyens puis la reconstruction
des maisons qui sont situées à deux
montagnes le water skweres c'est un
bassin inondables qui peut retenir les
eaux de pluie pendant les crues ici
c'est le terrain de sport qui était
devenue en 2010 est un véritable lac de
la rétention d'eau de manière à ce que
les enfants qui ont été inondées en 2010
ne reçoivent pas le même la même hauteur
d'eau qu'ils ont eu en 2010 est donc le
bassin cerveau permettent de retenir
l'eau pour ensuite à la fin de la crue
renvoyer l'ovaire par les réseaux des
municipalités dans la rivière des
instruments de mesure de l'eau sont
prévues dans une quarantaine d'endroits
dans la région la cartographie des zones
inondables de la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal est
pratiquement terminé ces zones seront
visibles en temps réel et en trois
dimensions sur internet
les résidents pourront voir d'avancer
leurs maisons sont menacées
les solutions proposées tiendront compte
des changements climatiques pays à
l'échelle de la région et c'est un
modèle qu'on va pied à l'échelle de la
région effectivement le plan final de
deux montagnes a été approuvé la phase
suivante consistera à remplacer les
digues temporaires
enfin tout rires c'est réparé pour ce
travail est plus une façon de mieux
environnementalement parlant favre être
quelque chose de beaucoup plus succincts
beaucoup plus à l'aise aussi bien donc
tu vas pas mal de maintenance comme on
les travaux dureront d'août à décembre
le modèle de deux montagnes sera ensuite
appliqué à toute la communauté urbaine
il devrait éliminer une fois pour toutes
les risques d'inondations dans la grande
région de montréal